How you doing?
[Silence]
Come here.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
we have now arrived at the first
condition of the nine conditions of
salah. That first condition is
the time of salah. That's the first
condition. So there are nine conditions
to salah.
All of these have to be in place in
order for your prayer to even start. In
order for your prayer to have any chance
of being valid, these nine things have
to be put in order. The first of these
nine things is
the time for prayer. Now we've mentioned
already one of these nine
conditions of salah. This is really the
second one
because the first one is what?
Huh?
Yeah. Right.
And we've also mentioned
which means purifying the clothing, the
body and the place of salah. So really
we've already done two. This is number
three. So in the book of salah this is
the first one. He mentions here a
narration. This narration is going to be
the centerpiece
and we're going to build on the meanings
and knowledge that we take from this
narration just we did with just
we did with just we did with
the narration of for the narration of
for the narration of
for. So now we are going to use this
narration. It is a narration of
regarding the timings of prayer.
[Silence]
forch.
So in this narration,
Jabar the son of Abdullah his father
Abdullah is a companion.
As a matter of fact, his father is a
martyr. Was martyed in the battle of
Urud and he is one of the few companions
that is known to have been killed by way
of what we would call today friendly
fire. He was accidentally killed by the
Muslim in the chaos of the day of Jab.
Narrates that the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam
was
descended upon by Jirel.
Jirel came to him and he said to him,
"Pray."
So he made
as soon as the sun crossed the zenith.
What is the zenith? The zenith is the
exact center of the sky.
Okay? If we were if we were located
exactly right smack dab in the middle on
the equator or very close to the equator
where Mecca or Medina are where the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam was and
time
the sun would be exactly smack dab in
the middle of the sky. That is just
before. When is zhour? Is as soon as the
sun crosses from the morning hemisphere
from the eastern hemisphere crosses the
exact center
into the western hemisphere. This is
called zed. And this is when the time of
begins.
This is when the time of dhar begins off
of the equator. Arizona, we're a little
bit closer. But you go up in northern
places and even here, how would we judge
the zenith? If you were to put a stick
in the ground
and the sun were to rise,
that shade is going to move as the sun
moves this way. When the shade moves
exactly parallel in the center with the
stick, that's the zen the zenith. Once
it crosses into
the once the shadow is pointing towards
the east and the sun is on the western
side this is called vh and that's
exactly what the word noon means in in
English noon is the zenith the exact
center of the sky high noon when the sun
is exactly in the center of the sky this
is exactly the halfway point before be
between sunrise and sunset.
So bhar begins once it crosses the
zenith towards the towards the evening
side that is called afternoon and that
is when bhar begins. Jirel then came to
him at the time of and he said prayer
stand and pray and so he prayed that day
once
everything's shade was its own length.
Okay. So he says he prayed
once everything's shade was its own
length. This is assur. Then he came to
him at time and he said stand and pray.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam prayed as soon as
meaning as soon as the disc of the sun
sank behind the behind the western
horizon. He could no longer see the dis
of the sun. This is the time for me. He
says, "And then he came to him at isa
time and he said, make is stand and
pray." And so he stood and prayed
as soon as the redness in the western
horizon was gone from from sunset. that
redness that red twilight that's in the
western
you know horizon
between
and once that redness is completely gone
that's the start of
he says and he then came to him at fudil
and he said stand and pray pray fudgel
so he made fudgel as soon as the eastern
horizon lit up. As soon as it lit up, he
made fud.
As we're going to learn, there are two
two fudger times. There's what is
referred to as the false
and the real fud.
False fud has three indicators that it
is not real fudger.
Real fud is when the let's focus on real
fud now is when the eastern horizon
lights up and the light is all
connected. There's no dark line between
the horizon and the light above it. This
is called real.
Okay. So he made that day.
[Silence]
for
rather
he then came to him the next day at time
when everything's
shade was its same length
and he said pray
I'll explain what that means in a moment
and so he prayed vo
didn't we day that he prayed the day
before when everything's shade was its
length its same length. So what does
that mean? What's meant when assur
starts because of the wording of this
narration the scholars tell us
begins
when everything's shade is its same
length plus the little addition when the
afternoon began.
Okay, what does that mean? Again, we
take our stick, we stick it in the
ground, the sun rises, it's in the
middle. There's no shade. There's zero
shade. Okay?
You can't see any shade. This is not bor
yet.
Then it goes across the zenith towards
the western hemisphere.
Now we have what? a small addition of
shade that will be pointing towards the
east.
That is when begins. When there's a
small bit of shade, when there's no
shade, there's no
when there's a small bit of shade,
meaning the sun just went across the
zenith, that's when bhar starts. Vhor
ends
when everything is its exact length
begins
when everything is its exact length plus
the little addition from
so when everything is slightly longer
than that its shade is slightly longer
than everything that's when when assur
begins.
He then came to him at Assur when the
shade of everything was twice its length
and he said pray now. And so he prayed.
Then he came to him at the same time
that that he did the day before for me
at the beginning of the time of and he
said pray now.
Which means that is short. It should
always be prayed as soon as it enters.
Then he came to him at the middle of the
night or after the first third of the
night had passed and he said to him,
"Pray Aisha." And so he prayed. The
middle of the night is not 12:00
midnight. The middle of the night is the
center moment
between me and fud.
You take the time of sunset and the time
of the break of dawn. The middle point
between those two that is called the
middle of the night in Islamic law.
He then came to him at fud the next day
when things were very bright out but the
sun had not quite risen and he said pray
and so he prayed fud. After this Gibl
said to the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
between these each of these two times is
the time for salah. Between each of
these two times is your time for salah.
Okay, we set down the tracks. Now, we're
going to start riding the train down the
tracks tomorrow, inshallah.
there's some things to unpack from
this narration which we will discuss
tomorrow morning.
[Arabic recitation]